they burn him author of a law unto
itself power politics in the IRS why a
book on the IRS well I think the IRS is
the single most powerful instrument of
social control in the United States I
think it's one of the two or three most
powerful law-enforcement agencies in the
world I also think that the American
press New York Times Washington Post
Wall Street Journal myself have ignored
this agency and it desperately needs
coverage why has it been ignored it's
complicated it requires you know I
worked on this book for years it
required a lot of digging there's a myth
out that the tax code is the important
part of tax enforcement and you know you
talk to academics and you talk to
lawyers in this town and they will say
oh the IRS is boring it's this cold
that's what drives this thing well
that's ridiculous that's that's arguing
to me I mean the parallel to that
argument is if you were in New York and
asked to cover crime control and you
went up to Albany and you know you wrote
about the legislature changing the crime
code a little bit and you didn't cover
the New York Police Department he didn't
cover who they are hiring and all of
that and so I thought it was time to
take a real detail hard-nosed I hope
even-handed look at this big agency that
affects all of us how big is it it's 123
thousand people now that's five times
bigger than the FBI that's twice the
size of the CIA it has far more
formidable legal powers than the FBI the
Congress in its wisdom has given the IRS
just ferocious legal powers to take
documents to make what they call
jeopardy assessments what have you it
has more information about more of us
than any other organization and you put
that all together
and as I say I think you have the single
most powerful law-enforcement agency in
this country where is it we're in it's
everywhere the headquarters of course
are here in Washington there are seven
regions around the country then and then
there are 63 districts and one of the
problems i think is the whole agency is
sold balkanized I think the Commissioner
here in Washington they usually serve
for two or three years they don't really
know what's going on and the agency is
run by old time government employees who
spent their whole life in this agency
they love it they're smart nice people
they I'm sure well-intentioned people
but they care more they come to care
more about the organization perhaps then
they care about the American people in
the back of your book you do have this
chart and you can't see it very well on
television but you show where all the
different service centers are and
where's the most powerful location I
can't really answer that in the there is
it that's the map of the how the IRS is
organized back in that part I have
prepared tables showing that if you live
in San Francisco you're five times more
likely to be audited than you've live in
New Jersey or three times more four
times more and if you live in Nashville
your six times more likely to have
seizures the rate of seizures and that
is six times higher than it is in
Richmond Virginia and the IRS allows
taxpayers you when it's decided that a
taxpayer owes money you are able
sometimes to enter into an agreement to
installment plan pay it off slowly and
that makes a lot of sense I have rates
showing that there's some districts
where you are ten times more likely to
be able to enter into a installment
agreement than others this raises
questioned me about bad management I
mean this is a national agency enforcing
a national law why isn't it more
even-handed across the country over the
years first of all how long is the IRS
been in
business well the IRS dates itself from
the Civil War essentially that's a
continuous agency the tax the income tax
came in just before World War one in
fact however one of the first acts of
the first Congress was to create a tax
agency to go out and collect the whiskey
tax which was one of the first things
that Congress passed and you I'm sure
remember there was a big rebellion on
that and George Washington the president
sent a big army out busted it up dragged
back the whiskey farmers the corn
farmers from western Pennsylvania and
there was a trial in Philadelphia and
they were convicted of tax evasion is
one of the first formal enforcement acts
of the federal government taxes are the
single most important thing of any
government over the years have there
been people that have become familiar to
the American people who have run the IRS
or is it faceless it's facelets it's run
by the the bureaucrats the commissioners
have come and gone I think old
Washington hands I mean people have been
around here remember Morty Kaplan who
was president kennedy's IRS commissioner
people around in Washington remember
sheldon cohen who was Lyndon Johnson's
Commissioner but then none of them have
had that sort of the became the figures
that Jagger Hoover did and in a way
that's good I mean Jagger Hoover led the
FBI in the wrong direction but in
another way you really have faceless
bureaucrats running it and i think the
commissioners in fact don't run it they
don't know what's going on it's run by
the senior civil servants how does the
commissioner get his or her job and has
ever been a woman heading it up never
been a woman there women don't fare too
well in the IRS you get it by being
appointed by the president in recent
years it's tended to be a tax lawyer I
don't think tax lawyers are always the
best
the administrator the new man a guy
named Fred Goldberg is a sort of
interesting because he taught political
science and economics before getting his
law degree and I suspect he may have a
broader sort of outlook of taxes in the
place of taxes and the importance of the
agency than some of his predecessor did
any of the IRS commissioners talked to
you many did not the larry gibbs who
just retired refused to talk to me he
said it wasn't in his interest but
Sheldon poen talked to me Don Alexander
who was a commissioner right at the end
of the Nixon administration was brought
in to sort of clean it up I think I went
to see him he's a tax lawyer in this
town and we were just talking very
casually and he said you know that tax
laws it's brought me great despair at
some point he said you know one of the
worst things that happened to me when I
was a young lawyer for covington burling
this was about nineteen fifty two it's
an astonishing story coming umbrella in
the law firm a law firm which is the
sort of distinguished law firm and he
said we were trying to get through a tax
ruling and we couldn't get it through
for for a big corporate several
corporations he said we couldn't get it
through we couldn't get it through and
Don Alexander said we decided to go
political and he said they approached
alben Barkley son-in-law who was son of
a fixer in the Truman administration
whose album Barkley alben Barkley I'm
sorry was the vice president at that
time and a lunch was arranged with the
Treasury secretary a man named Schneider
and it lunch was held at the
Cosmopolitan Club the you know the the
Metropolitan Club I'm sorry the
Metropolitan and Don Alexander said a
twenty-five-thousand-dollar bribe was
paid and they got the tax ruling the
next day are there and I know you read
the chapter on there are there many
bribes today the IRS there is a major
problem I think of corruption that is
all
across the country we live in a age of
sort of wheeling dealing I mean the
whole 80s of the bow skis and the
savings and loan people don't like to
pay taxes and I think the evidence shows
there were big corruption problems in
philadelphia and chicago and los angeles
and a number of other places and more
disturbingly the evidence shows that the
IRS sort of backed away from a fierce
stance on corruption during that period
there you know every agency like this
has a Inspection Division an
anti-corruption force during the 80s the
managers of the IRS allowed the
Inspection Division to get smaller and
smaller in relationship to the overall
IRS and that meant of course that each
inspector had more to do and therefore
could do it less well and I think there
was a growing corruption problem during
the 80s now the new man is worried about
that and it started putting more people
back in but there were a lot of cases
Brian that came out just recently during
my reporting and during a congressional
hearing where senior executives got into
corrupt situations were discovered were
spotted and then allowed to sort of
escape punishment I mean there's a case
in Los Angeles where the man in charge
of the criminal investigating unit in
Los Angeles was offered a big job by the
guests company which is a big
manufacturing company he then arranged
for the IRS to go go into a great raid
against guesses leading commercial
opponent which is Jordache and just a
couple of months ago the US attorney in
New York said the evidence against
Jordache did not warn indictment and it
was thrown away nothing happened to the
man who arranged this hit for his for
this company that it offered them is
this major high-paying job and that kind
of thing we see around the country quite
a lot it's worrisome that's bad
management 15 years of the New York
Times yes during that time a number of
things that you wrote about led to
investigations serpico cervical that was
very important to this book i covered
the New York Police Department for from
67 to 74 and the near police departments
very much like the IRS or there are a
lot of parallels it's a big old
organization it's headed by
commissioners who come and go it's
actually run by the I don't like the
civil servants that suggests that their
servants to the people and I think their
public employees and some of them are
civil servants and some art both the
police department in the IRS have a lot
of power down at the bottom you know the
cop on the street has is authorized to
shoot you if you do certain things he's
authorized to take away he or she is
authorized to take away your liberty the
IRS agent has a lot of power and to
supervise that is very hard and requires
really tough smart work and when i
covered the new york police department i
love the big bureaucracies and I
understand how hard they are to work and
I respect many of the people in them but
I'm pretty hard-nosed about them and I
think the IRS and the New York Police
Department have many of the same
problems you also and only take you
through the whole story but you still
the islands I know your background you
also were involved the karen silkwood
okay yeah I covered a lot of stuff on
nuclear power and that led to being
involved in the karen silkwood thing and
she when she had her accident she was on
her way to give you documents is that
that is true in the book you write that
as you talked to
hundreds of thousands of people for this
book it's inevitably somebody if it was
a lunch with leaned across the table and
say to you you better have a good
account yeah what were they getting that
everybody would make that little joke
they'd smile and hope you've taken care
of your tax affairs friend and so and so
and really almost everybody did that I
mean Commissioner Goldberg when I saw
him last week did not do it and when I
saw the deputy IRS commissioner he did
not make that little joke but almost
everybody else did and I think it's a
really telling commentary on what the
American people i mean you know this is
not a scientific survey but an awful lot
of american people think that the IRS
would harass someone who was just doing
a job of reporting just being critic
that's what we think I mean that's a lot
of cynicism built into that little joke
and that's one of the problems as our
cynicism I thing how did you approach
the book and when did you first get the
idea well about four years ago a little
more than four years ago I was in the
news room of the Washington bureau of
the New York Times and a young reporter
named Steve angle Berg looked up at me
and he said something the fact will burn
them you worked on the New York Police
Department you've written a lot about
computers you ought to do a book on the
IRS and I said boy that's a good idea
and I decided to quit the x and go to
work on this book doing the book
involved things like I spent a lot of
times in presidential libraries and I
got there was a lot of interesting stuff
I went to for example i went up to Hyde
Park FDR's library and I saw there I
found some documents showing that and we
ought to maybe talk about this some wash
show showing that FDR was at least as
abusive in his use of the IRS as Richard
Nixon and many other presidents have
been very abusive
the IRS have really used it LBJ did john
f kennedy so the presidential libraries
were good i did a lot of interviews Don
Alexander knocked me off my feet when he
told me about as a young lawyer how his
bosses bribed the Treasury secretary I
have a lot of sort of whistleblowers who
talked to me I had some whistleblowers
who gave me internal audit reports
within the IRS which the IRS tries to
really keep down the internal audit
reports show for example that the IRS is
very sloppy in how it protects
computerized information it does not
follow the rules that it's supposed that
it that its own rules the General
Accounting Office which is the
investigative arm of the Congress for
the last 15 years has been doing reports
on the IRS and I got all of those as you
know that's a heavy heavy reading
burdens they sometimes done some great
reports and they sometimes them's and
some bad report but looking at them over
time is really quite interesting I mean
an example just a couple of weeks ago
the GAO put out a report saying that
one-third of the telephone questions
that the IRS gets that one third of them
they answer incorrectly and at the back
of this little report was a letter from
the new commissioner saying this is no
good mr. Goldberg this is no good and
I'm going to really work on this in the
coming year well because i had read a
lot of these old reports i remembered
that 1975 the GAO said the same thing 15
years ago and Don Alexander said were
going to deal with this and they said it
1980 and they promised to fix it and
they said it in 87 and they promised to
fix it and they don't and so you see in
New York mean not in New York a
newspaper would write a story about this
little GAO report two weeks ago and let
it go with that and everyone would say
ho hum
they've said that before but the point
is this has been brought to the
attention of this agency and it has
failed to deal with it and it gets
serious page 142 in conjunction what you
said about thirty percent our third of
the people that call the IRS for
information get wrong information you
right over the past years the IRS has
been extremely attentive to the judges
congressman and the White House staff
members who were in a position to
influence the fortunes of the agency
then you say until very recently for
example the IRS routinely provided
personal tax advice to any Supreme Court
justice member of Congress or White
House staffer why just until recently I
think they got embarrassed about it it
got in a little of that got into the
press and I picked up this business
about Supreme Court I had heard about
doing the White House staff matter of
fact I found some memos in the
presidential libraries saying you know
next week the IRS will be here to help
any White House staffer who needs
assistance and I had run across that in
Congress when I was interviewing a
senior retired official he said that
just just a few years ago that he had
been called down and had prepared the
tax return for a member of the Supreme
Court who's on the bench today and he
said he didn't think that was right and
in fact that judge who is a you know
fine person has not refused himself on
IRS cases even though he had this thing
of value given to him by the IRS I'm
sure it may not have occurred to him but
that actually violates the code of
ethics of the Supreme Court can any
citizen go to the IRS and get the same
treatment no its senior IRS executive
comes to your office and helps you write
your tax return well let me let me ask
you that I mean you can can you go to
the IRS if you are a citizen and get
them to help you write your tax return
yes in theory but
I don't think this tax return done to
the Supreme Court justice one third of
it was wrong I'll tell you I bet it was
done right and having an IRS agent a
senior IRS official do what I would bet
would be an absolute guarantee you'd
never be audited too and of course if
the IRS gives you the wrong information
on the phone or wrong information in
letter and you're audited tough they
don't do it anymore they don't do the
Supreme Court of the white house anymore
they still set up an office in the
Congress and members of Congress or
staff can come in and get advice it's
not quite as blatant as it used to be
and they insist that would be open to
anyone who happened to come in the
capital you know any citizen I mean the
ice theoretically I could come in and
get tax advice but I think it's unlikely
that I would know what the room number
was where the IRS are sitting to help
you let me go back to how you got this
job done did you leave that new york
times before you had a publisher no I
went to Random House my publisher and we
talked about it and they said they would
like to do it and they offered an
advance and then I was reasonably
confident I could get some additional
money from some foundations I won the
Alicia Patterson fellowship which is a
wonderful foundation that gives five or
six fairly substantial grants each year
to investigative books and a couple of
other foundations came in the J Roderick
MacArthur Foundation Deer Creek
foundation and supported me in the
writing of this book said you visited
that presidential libraries did you know
that was going to take you four years to
get this job done no it was longer than
I thought it was going to take and I
could have I think it would be a better
book if I'd spent another year the
stories are very hard to tease out you
take a look you get a little nibble here
and a little nibble there and you put it
together and I mean it's great fun I was
a history major in college and I
I loved it but and when when you sort of
dotted and I I mean I tell a story in
the book about Morgenthau approving what
was an essence of bribe to a businessman
in Louisiana who was providing them
information on hewing lon the Roosevelt
administration was going after huey long
because he was the major political
threat in 36 and i ran across the story
first in a auto biography written by an
old iris men long out of date then i
found some documents in the hyde park
where Morgenthau was specific what old
about the bribe and it's approved I mean
it really is quite blatant and
interesting the bribe was alone from the
reconstruction Finance Corporation to
this guy I then went down to the
National Archives and started searching
for the record of the actual loan I
found an index card where the loan is
described and on the index card it says
there's a little notation saying we're
unable to locate the actual records and
it looks like the actual records of this
loan were lifted so that no one could
find the story but the index card was
left in there and it confirmed the
substantial loan that was made to the
the janky brothers in New Orleans who
were apparently providing dirt on their
enemy Huey after four years of research
and writing this book you feel
differently about the IRS and when you
started yeah I think it's a bigger
problem than I thought I'd say I mean we
are confronted with a bigger kind of
challenge than I thought originally but
I think the fundamental problem is that
both
the public and the Congress and the IRS
have become so cynical we also say
that's the way it is where you know
nothing AAA why bother that reform is
very very difficult simplifying the tax
laws almost in I mean it's a really
tough thing to get through Congress for
a bunch of institutional reasons over
there making such an organization work
as hard getting some enthusiasm and some
some hard work out of an old tired
bureaucracy is really tough I am
convinced it can be done I saw this
happen in New York City I saw the Knapp
Commission and the special prosecutor
and the new commissioner Patrick Murphy
who was a brilliant guy and I saw him
change recruiting and changed training
and changed the way management was
working and getting in some new
equipment and stuff and I think it was
improved I mean the police service was
improved everybody in New York said that
wasn't going to happen they said yeah
there's always going to be corruption
yeah you know I well I think we can do
it but it's going to it's really hard
but she also said that after it was
improved in New York City had slid back
to where at least i know he said it back
to where it was but it went back
democracy is hard making democracy work
is hard and this is a big organization
that's been given vast powers and to fit
it into our due process system requires
enormous work I am very critical of the
Ways and Means Committee and the Finance
Committee and the members of that for
failing to do oversight that is required
I mean you know the Finance Committee up
until a couple of years ago when David
Pryor took over had never ever held a
single oversight hearing on the IRS and
the ever in history never in history
there have been a few Senate
investigations one was a special
committee one was a judiciary
subcommittee and one was an
appropriation subcommittee but the
finance committee the committee that's
supposed to do oversight never when the
house government operations committee
last summer under Doug Barnard started
investigating well earlier than last
summer's started investigating
corruption the ways Means Committee
desperately tried to stop that
investigation from happening and they
worked very very hard to stop it and
Doug Barnard was very stubborn and kept
at it and and you know a summer had a
very good and responsible hearing and
brought out some things and the new
commissioner is now adopting some
changes that should have been done a
long time ago and you know what taxes
are so vital I mean all the congressmen
and I love them I love Congress but
they're partly in the business of
sending money back to the districts for
schools and highways and all of that and
they all are terribly worried about that
money machine somehow getting out of
whack and there's a great temptation
don't mess with the IRS don't touch it
just leave it alone money's coming in
and we'll have it there to vote for all
the good things that our constituents
want and we've got to be much tougher
with this agency I think you said that
Lawrence gives did not cooperate and
several other officials as you work
through this process did you find people
not taking your phone calls at the IRS
oh yeah just wouldn't return the call
never I mean I had a very funny occasion
I have a story in here during the Reagan
administration where the a group high
school science teachers in Minnesota
came to the IRS and they wanted to form
a little tax-exempt group to promote the
idea of Darwinism of evolution pretty
controversial right
and they got a letter back from a man
named Peter bras signed by Peter bras
and it was written by a crazy I mean it
sounded like it was written by a very
very I don't mean crazy but a very
sincere creationist and he said who are
you to say that the creationist view
isn't right and are you going to give
equal time to the creationists and who
says that evolution is the true theory
and the group was very political and
it's you know smart in a savvy way and
they went to their senator and the
senator raised a little questions and
the IRS came back the Commissioner came
back and said Oh what they completely
wrong I couldn't understand that they
didn't understand of course they can
have time exemption and all of that now
what's interesting about this story is I
called Peter bras and asked him to
return my call and now i don't know
maybe he didn't get the message maybe he
was at a conference or something but
anyone no one ever called back and after
the story appeared i got a call from i
shall say a close associate it is i
don't want to sell him this was a
private call and the person said peter
bras had not signed the letter that he's
the head of a large unit in the IRS and
he has a whole mess of people under him
and of course he was responsible but he
knew nothing about the letter going out
or coming in and and i heard that he was
very upset that i had used his name i
had the document i had the it was signed
by his name it didn't say sign for
somebody else but what's interesting is
assuming that story's true this is an
organization that's so bit big that that
kind of letter goes out without the
supervisor seeing it and how you know
how can you control an agency of 123
thousand people that kind of span of
control that that the head of a unit
doesn't see an important letter like
that did you find that often people knew
who you were and knew what you were
working on but wouldn't talk to him
uh yeah word gets around the IRS Barry
there's a real gossip link and a lot of
people weren't won't talk to you there
are some people who will talk and gossip
me one of the problems was to throw out
the untruths I mean the criminal
division especially gossips in a just a
ferocious way and they tell terrible
stories about each other I mean they're
always saying that so-and-so is in
organized crime and so and so's this and
everything and without any evidence of
it and so you had to be very cautious
with some of this casual gossip and then
others wouldn't talk to you and we're
future you know mr. Bross initially he
wrote me a letter saying that he didn't
he didn't say he wasn't responsible but
he said he hadn't that he hadn't
actually signed the letter and why
didn't I come to him well I had tried to
come to him in your acknowledgments are
several other names you use and I asked
you about them only because if somebody
picks us up and read it there are
certain associations that people
automatically make for instance with the
American Civil Liberties Union you say
here I Jerry Berman and Morton halperin
of the American Civil Liberties Union
generously offered me a year of office
space is that a problem to associate
yourself with the ACLU I don't think so
I mean what happened was I quit the New
York Times I found that working at home
was I'm glad you brought it up I found
that working at home was difficult than
I kept going down to kitchen eating all
the time and I was sort of looking for
an office and Jerry Berman who I had
covered as a reporter for The New York
Times a lot said they had an empty it
turned out to be sort of a closet and
what I like to do it so I you know I put
a desk in this closet I got my own phone
line and on my own computer and it was
very I mean and that's the way I worked
for about a year and it was terrific
their office here in Washington is
fairly close to where I live and then
the advocacy institute mike perchick did
the same thing for a period and
when another foundation grant came
through i actually started paying rent
to the advocacy institute just to avoid
that problem in the front of your book
you have a dedication and our audience
will soon ceded its to Molly Sarah and
Joanne who's that Molly MA Molly's my
youngest daughter a lovely 22 year old
woman and Sarah's 26 in my older
daughter elder daughter i think is the
proper grammar and Joanna's my wife was
a reporter at The Washington Post Joanna
mang Joanne oh my yes who our audience
has seen yes any occasion by the way are
you planning to go back to writing again
for a major newspaper no I'm begun work
on a project about project and I hope
book on the Justice Department daily
journalism get tired of it get tired of
it you can't dig in enough you can't
Emily journalism is often it's often
superficial and there are pressures on
most of the papers now to become more
superficial I think you know I found
that fascinating that neither I mean I
can't remember whether we talked about
neither the post at the times of the
Wall Street Journal has a full-time
person assigned to cover the IRS and I
don't think any of the papers have ever
covered the Justice Department they
cover handouts from the Justice firm
they don't cover what the Justice
Department does and I'd like to dig into
that and sort of look at all of the
deals you know at all covering
bureaucracy is really hard and we just
don't do it very much and one of the
reasons it's so hard is that often what
a bureaucracy doesn't do is more
important than what it does do during
the Reagan administration for example
the IRS was brought overwhelming
evidence that the Catholic Church was
violating the law in its active
involvement in politics on the abortion
issue now I'm not getting into who's
right and wrong on the abortion issue
that's not the question here but hard
paper concrete evidence was brought to
them over and over again the IRS
acknowledged it but they did not and God
knows it would have been difficult they
did not take away the tax exemption of
the Catholic Church as required by law
now the pro-choice people had to live
within the restrictions of law and they
didn't have this madness source of
considerable funds and backing so this
act this is non act had a major
political consequence during the Reagan
years and it fit the political agenda of
the Reagan years I'm not saying that
President Reagan ordered them to do it
but no I'm not saying that at all but
i'm sure the IRS was aware of the
political reality here and it clearly
was a difficult situation for them to be
in but in fact they didn't enforce the
law does the IRS and your look at the
past and present under a Republican
administration and a Democratic
administration deal with the law
differently yes but you don't really say
Republican and under each administration
there's a different sort of emphasis
during and sometimes its presidential
hits sometimes you can really tie it to
jamming there's a piece of paper that I
can't I JFK to a program to go after
right-wing fundamentalist ministers who
are criticizing there are some papers I
can't I FDR to some stuff other times
the IRS just as sort of the bureaucracy
does it I don't think Harry Truman
ordered the IRS in the early 50s to
close down to try to close down the calm
this party I think that was a district
director in New York on his own said
he'll let's go close down the Communist
Party he went and slapped padlocks on it
the charge the Communist Party had not
paid any taxes well that was true the
only problem was that no political party
had ever been required to pay taxes
Republican Democrat socialist and that
was the agency I think sister Lucy and
this group of high school science
teaches out in Minnesota I don't think
that was done you know with any kind of
White House and I think they just
thought that was what they wanted there
was an Achaean the Ford administration
where a group of serious group of New
York people who were gay wanted to form
a foundation to do research on gay life
they came to the IRS the IRS that will
give you a tax exemption if you agree
never to go on radio or television we
don't want you corrupting the minds of
the little children can you imagine that
if you agree not to quote the American
Psychiatric Association's opinion on gay
life and they said no we won't do it and
so they didn't get tax exemption so this
research did not go forward it might
have been very well if we'd had that
research given what's happened the AIDS
business since the lawyer who handled
that case thinks it was because there
was a senior person in the IRS who was a
homophobe he didn't think Jerry Ford
said don't do this it's just so much
power that we need to make it public and
get it out and to look at it maybe the
tax exemption should be taken away from
the IRS completely by the way how many
people are audited every year tiny tiny
tiny fraction less than 1 percent and
how does that come about well if you ask
the IRS they will tell you that is
because they have this computerized
system that selects all of these people
and then you're audited that is quite
misleading there is a computerized
system that makes the first slice but
the first slice they
includes about four times more taxpayers
than could ever be audited in the given
year and so this big pile of tax returns
are taken and put into the district
office and then they sort of go through
and by guessing by golly they pull the
return that looks interesting or good
and of course there are a lot of decent
well-meaning IRS agents and and they're
selecting returns for good and proper
reasons however because there's this
great discretion you sometimes get
people being audited and harassed who
just because there's a personal vendetta
I had to stories have been that as one
involves a nice respectable upper-class
I guess you call him Boyer in Miami
named Dan Heller dan Heller represented
the Miami Daily News 15 years ago the
Miami Daily News ran a story about the
IRS and the iris didn't like it the IRS
came in and demanded to see The Daily
News's notes dan Heller said no there
was an angry exchange of words in the
process and two agents in the room at
the time was mr. plow and Mr Lopez ten
years goes by and mr. plow Mr Lopez get
the idea that they're going to audit and
look at mr. Heller they do they find
something that they think looks a little
suspicious they go to mr. Heller's
accountant they put a great deal of
pressure on the accountant they threaten
the accountant you know they say you're
going to go to jail you're really in
deep trouble mister and the accountant
becomes so frightened that he comes into
court and he lies about Dan Heller he
perjures himself dan Heller is convicted
he spends four months in jail federal
prison and at that point a court of
appeals looks into it and told a story
and Dan Heller is sprung but you know
his reputation has been badly damaged
because once the IRS says that man is a
tax cheat people don't forget that
that's of sticks in your head you know
this guilty innocent until proven guilty
is a very fine thing but anyone who's
been accused knows that there are a lot
of people who don't believe it and of
course his business was you know his law
firm was badly interrupted and that kind
of thing can happen was he able to go
back and practice law yes he's the the
Bar Association has given back his you
know his he's recovered he won a large
suit insurance company of the accountant
paid of large damages and he currently
is suing the two agency of what they
call a Blevins suit isn't it living I
think and trying to get damages I didn't
notice that you said that there was an
estimate he got five million from his
insurance company but there was an
estimate that he'd lost eight million in
revenue during the time that was tied up
and let the cost of cost of attorney how
often have you found that to be the case
where no even if you get off when you've
been wrong it costs you a lot more money
well there's an incredible story i came
across fairly recently of a nice couple
in North Carolina in the K and Alex
council and the IRS came after k in and
locks and they said you owe X amount of
taxes they said no we don't and they
were discussing you know their
accountant was in there going back and
forth all of a sudden without any notice
the iris seized their assets Alex was
outraged because the law and procedures
everything says you've got to have
notice so he went into federal court and
he started fighting and he fought it
took a lot of time and a lot of money
after a couple of years their assets
have been seeds they ran out of money
Alex became distraught became just
thoroughly upset one day he went out and
shot himself behind in the woods behind
their house and they had an insurance
thing that paid them off even though it
was a suicide and his note k showed me
the note you know was this is the only
choice we have to beat the IRS and k
kept the legal battle going and the
court about four months after he
committed suicide a rule that the they
there hadn't been a notice that it was
improper etc the court gave k council 22
thousand dollars in legal fees that's
only half of what she owes at this point
and her lawyers have told her she has no
chance of recovering damages it's a
tough agency and the decisions I mean
here's you know she won the battle but
she lost the war I mean it's just it's a
tragic story who in your opinion which
President was the worst offender of or
misuse using the tax law to a political
advantage Nixon and FDR ran
neck-and-neck in that division I mean as
far as I can look at the record each
president know that he was doing that
yes and what were the differences in the
two or what kind of things that they use
it for well you remember Nixon
used the IRS powers to embarrass the
governor of alabama Governor los
governor Wallace governor Wallace his
brother had some tax problems they got
the information and they leaked it and
you know Nixon used it I mean that's
very similar to Huey Long the same kind
of thing only in Huey's long case they
were trying to put Huey Long in jail it
wasn't just a matter of him leaking a
little embarrassing information about
FDR FDR knew about the Huey Long thing
he was involved in the selection of the
prosecutor of the first law not the case
against ue but the one of them Huey's
lieutenants was actually indicted and
FDR was involved in selecting the
prosecutor for that case personally
let's say you're president of the United
States and you've got the IRS sitting
over there how do you effectively use it
what's the system can you just pick up
the phone and call the IRS commissioner
say I want this done but how does it
actually happened you mentioned the next
administration has a felon in with Clark
Mullen hof mm-hmm is that the way it's
done and explain what he did well it's
interesting the I got to get this right
the Nixon administration asked for and
got some information on Larry O'Brien
and Larry O'Brien somehow heard about it
at the time he was head of the
Democratic National Democratic National
Committee and so Larry O'Brien and
Sheldon Cohen who was LBJ's IRS
commissioner and Morty Kaplan who was
Kennedy's IRS commissioner put out a
joint statement saying this is
outrageous political use of the IRS and
were shocked well a Republican senator
named John Williams
who was from Delaware was an old very
honorable very tough tight-fisted guy
and he'd always hated the IRS and he dug
into it and he discovered that Nixon in
fact had set up a written procedure
under which a given White House person
could get information from the the IRS
and you can make an argument that in
certain cases you're going to appoint
somebody that that's alright but there
was in the Nixon administration a
written procedure for doing it John
Williams discovered that are in the
Kennedy administration there was no
written procedure at all it was just
done john f kennedy's sort of senior
investigator and Bobby's the day after
they were went into the White House he
was at the IRS going through files
looking at enemies and there was no
written procedure all presidents have
done this I think LBJ probably was right
up there there's some indications that
but LBJ was much smarter than Nixon and
Kennedy and covering his trail and the
the the tracks of it are very slim
there's an early case involving LBJ
where the IRS investigated Brown & Root
which was one of the big political
contributors to LBJ and had given a lot
of illegal campaign contributions to and
a hard-nosed IRS agent started
investigating this this is when LBJ was
still a House member and started
investigating it and made a ferocious
case and LB Brown and Root was about to
be get into serious trouble and that
would have been a very upsetting me with
ended LBJ's career LBJ went to FDR
personally and begged him to stop it and
LBJ FDR called in the IRS agent who had
done this and the case was dropped the
next day you suggest that another text
in the name of Sam Rayburn had a lock on
the tax process how did that happen oh
that was of course Sam Rayburn
you know was a very honorable man and
this what happened was that one of his
Democratic congressmen were being
investigated and he wanted to get the
thing done and he calls up I mean Sam
had so much power and authority in
Washington he called up the Republican
Commissioner at the time and said you
know I think what the way Sam put it
would have been very blunt but it was
something about do it or get off the pot
and and they came in and they said okay
we will not bring criminal charges
against him and this was for a
congressman that had a democratic
congressman whose vote Sam Rayburn
needed it was a favor that Sam Rayburn
did to get this issue resolved and later
on Sam used that favor to get this
congressman he was from Albany to cast a
vote against his constituent issue
interest in the in the in the interest
of the gas industry who Stan Rayburn as
a Texan of course was looking out for
there's another story about Eleanor
Roosevelt and Frank Gannett and the
reason I bring that up is today the
Gannett name is big in this country in
the media world there's a lot of
information about where Frank and that
came from might be a surprise to some
people well it was that story oh that's
that's an incredible story where a
freelance investigative writer sent
Eleanor Roosevelt a book in which he
made some claims about Gannett and who
was then a young publisher who owned a
small chain of papers up on the New York
State he also was the chairman of the
vice vice chairman Republican National
Committee and they also a member of the
board of Cornell or the chairman of the
board of Cornell University and finally
his newspapers had been raising hell
with FDR
and Eleanor read this and said that some
allegations were made about Jeanette and
Eleanor said how interesting and she
sent it over to Morgenthau now I don't
think mrs. Roosevelt intended for there
to be a big IRS investigation but there
was and at one point in fact it's
looking at the document you can see a
little handwritten note by mr.
Morgenthau in which he speculated
whether it be possible to take away the
tax exemption of cornell university
because of mr. gill nets business
relations with Gannett and the IRS came
back and said no we can't do that and
the matter was dropped but can you
imagine if we had evidence that mrs.
Nixon innocently had triggered some kind
of investigation of the owner of CBS or
something like that you know we would be
all up in arms but this is Roosevelt
seems to live in a different world at
about six minutes left and not nearly
enough time to cover everything our most
Americans honest with their taxes yes
what do you have any idea what the
percentages well it's hard to figure but
something like ninety percent you know
the IRS collects a trillion dollars a
year so an overwhelming majority of the
American people want to pay their taxes
and try to pay their taxes mr. Goldberg
the new commissioner in a tie to talk
with him a week or so ago and he said
what we've got to do is spend a lot more
time helping the compliant noose the
compliant taxpayer get pay his taxes we
got to make sure he gets the right
information then that the forms are
clear and simple and all of that and
we've got a because that's where the
money is of course we've got to continue
going after the bad guys but where the
where the real problem in the IRS is
that they don't do enough helping the
compliant which is a newspaper man the
compliant taxpayer have you seen how
long as you book been in the end the
bookstores a couple of weeks have you
seen any immediate result
any any reaction from the IRS or have
you heard that people are reading it a
lot of people are reading it was went it
went in the bookstores a couple of weeks
ago and there's as of now there's been
almost no publicity I mean there was one
review in Time magazine in the New York
Times and the poster coming next sunday
or this sunday or when it better coming
soon but two weeks ago was on the
bestseller list in the Washington Post I
presume because the IRS is reading at
congressional staffers are reading and
looking at it it's not a picture of you
and there's t-shirt on the cover yeah
sure is it is you that's absolutely kid
yes don't it doesn't look like me if
they had in the last part of the book
you have some recommendation about what
needs to be done a little a little
feeble if I think feeble in the in the
sense that you don't have enough I don't
have enough I wish I I just sort of ran
out of steam I mean I think we need much
better oversight I think we ought to
think about maybe taking tax exemption
away from the IRS putting it somewhere
else putting a distinguished panel
perhaps you know of educators and church
people and everything I mean why should
this police agency run the charity
business but saying more you know ending
cynicism I mean it's fine to say that
and I have seen an example where it
worked in New York City I think and I
think it can work here but I think a lot
of people will may read this and say no
doesn't he have a better remedy you know
the remedy the problem is us and the
remedy is in us and that's hard the last
line in your book got me thinking it's a
massive infusion of new blood is
required and it just what came to mind
when i read that was couldn't you apply
that to almost any institution in her
country absolutely but there's no
institution or a country that has so
much power and so much impact on all of
us and this this agency i think more
than most is inbred i mean there are
very few middle level and senior people
from out
side the agency it's there all people
who began there you know 25 years ago
and they've just kept in the agency the
Treasury Department put a report out I
found saying that and saying that we had
to have more people what's next you say
another book another book on the Justice
Department what else what are you doing
to pay the bills between now that book
well I've set up a new organization
called the transactional records access
clearinghouse a big mouthful track for
short and what we're doing is using
computers I've got a partnership with a
woman named Susan be long was a
professor at Syracuse University and
we're using computers to pull out
statistical information from federal
enforcement agencies and sort it out we
just put out a report based on a
computer file of five and a half million
federal court cases and we're able to
sort it out and what I hope to do is to
look at the NRC the Justice Department
the Food and Drug Administration what
have you and I have gotten some funding
from several foundations and we're part
of Syracuse University and we're going
to make this available to Congress to
newspapers to public interest groups and
to academics living here in Washington
living here in Washington and sue stays
up and with the computers humming in
Syracuse and when is the next book
expected to hit the standard I was four
or five years another four or five year
yeah look our guest for the last hour
has been the author of this book law
unto itself power politics in the IRS
David Burnham Thank You mr. mayor thank
you great to be here